well the war in ukraine has created the
biggest refugee crisis since the second
world war my next guest
well is planning on heading to the
ukraine poland border in an ambulance
that he and his family have bought to
help those injured as they flee the war
zone i'm very pleased to say that umrah
ali javid joins us now on the programme
omran great to see you this morning as i
understand it you're you're a student at
glasgow caledonian university
good to see you as well yeah i'm a
student studying international tourism
and event management at glasgow
california university
goodwin university that we've got my
little brother went there and it's also
producing someone like you so
tell us the thought behind all of this
buying an ambulance and driving up all
the way to the ukrainian border what
prompted this
well it's heartbreaking to see the
images and videos that are coming out of
ukraine
so i wanted to do something to help them
and i know that these ambulances they've
got distinct markings and you know and a
distinct color so they can help evacuate
innocent civilians and people with
disabilities through evacuation routes
and hopefully
that's what it's going to do because
it's going to be handed over to a
ukrainian charity
and do that
so when are you sent when are you
setting off imran i mean it's it's not
an easy drive at the best of times but
given that you know the place that
you're heading to is essentially on the
edge of a war zone might make it even
more problematic a journey
yeah yeah um basically i've got a class
um at university at 2 p.m and i finish
at 4 p.m after class i'm going straight
to the border and to england genga ferry
to the netherlands then into germany and
then into poland and then other
ukrainian border is where they're
meeting me and the charity
responsibility of the ambulance so it's
not really a big deal to be honest i've
done it many times i've took many
ambulances before so i should be there
by monday
yes tell us tell us then around just a
little bit about that i noticed that
this is not the first time that you've
done this you've taken ambulances to
burma syria iraq yemen places like that
this has been something you've been
doing for quite some time
yeah yeah i've been doing it for a few
years now and the first time
i went to the gaza strip with medical
supplies and i've seen a couple of
ambulances get through so i thought this
is like a really great idea to get and
to take ambulances where they're needed
and secondhand british ambulances are
really really and good that way to help
patients and get to the hospitals or
where they're needed at medical center
and it's just like heartbreaking to see
whenever i go to burma or these places
it's heartbreaking just to see what's
going on there
we're just looking at pictures of a very
apparently very peaceful and tranquil
key every wonder how
how long that will last for but just
just tell us
how have you paid for this because the
last time i well
my days as a student are very much in
the dim the dim and distant past but i
certainly didn't have two and a half
grand sitting in my bank account to go
off and buy an ambulance
yeah yeah so um
two days ago um i went to
the there's a retail shop here that
takes second-hand equipment so i sold
one on my graphics card
and i got 775 pounds for that it's like
they're not in demand there are in
demand these days and that will pay for
my fuel costs and stuff and i had some
savings left over i do like to save my
money but um you know just seeing what's
going on
i'm just trying to help in any way i can
and i think everyone's trying to do that
help like there's a lot of people in the
community that are trying to help in
their own way by donating money i could
like i'm able to donate an ambulance and
i know that it could make a difference
maybe
them to a few hundred people
but like it's not much of a difference
because tens of thousands of people need
help but at least i'll make some
difference
well done mate very good very good on
you drive safely and i hope you make it
back in time i'm told you've got classes
on tuesday you've got to be back for
yeah yeah so i hopefully i'll be back on
tuesday to be back in time for my class
and a family the university hopefully
will be easy on me
i'm just going to say if you need if you
need someone to write a letter and run
i'm i'm willing i'm putting my name
forward just give me a shout
drive safely and uh well look we'll
maybe speak to you when you get back um
ali chavez thank you so much for joining
us